so in this whole process
where does intelligence originate
would you say so
if we look at things that are much less
intelligent to humans
and you start to build up a human the
process of evolution
where's this magic thing that uh has a
prediction model or a model that's able
to predict
that starts to look a lot more like
intelligence is there a place where
richard dawkins wrote an introduction to
your uh to your book an excellent
introduction
i mean it puts a lot of things into
context
and it's funny just looking at parallels
for your book and
darwin's origin of species so darwin
wrote about the origin
of species so
what is the origin of intelligence well
we have a theory about it and it's just
that it's a theory
theory goes as follows as soon as living
things started to move
they're not just floating in sea they're
not just a plant
you know grounded someplace as soon as
they started the move
there was an advantage to moving
intelligently to moving in certain ways
and there's some very simple things you
can do you know bacteria or
single cell organisms can move towards a
source of gradient of
food or something like that but an
animal that might know where it is
and know where it's been and how to get
back to that place or an animal that
might
say oh there was a source of food
someplace how do i get to it or there
was a
danger how do i get to there was a mate
how do i get to them
there was a big evolution advantage to
that so early on there was a pressure to
start
understanding your environment like
where am i
and where have i been and what happened
in those different places
so we still have this neural mechanism
in our brains um it's in the in the
mammals
it's in the hippocampus and rhinocortex
these are older parts of the brain
um and these are very well studied um
we build a map of the of our environment
so
these neurons in these parts of the
brain know where i am in this room and
where the door was and things like that
so a lot of other
mammals have this all mammals have this
right and almost any
any animal that knows where it is and
get around must have some mapping system
must have some way of saying i've
learned a map of my environment
i have hummingbirds in my backyard and
they and they go the same places all the
time they have to
they must know where they are they just
know where they are when they're they're
not just randomly flying around they
know they know particular flowers they
come back to
so we all have this and it turns out
it's very
tricky to get neurons to do this to
build a map of an environment it's just
and so we now know there's this these
famous studies that's still very active
about
place cells and grid cells and these
other types of cells in the older parts
of the brain
and how they build these maps of the
world it's really clever it's obviously
been under a lot of evolutionary
pressure over a long period of time to
get good at this
so animals not know where they are what
we think has happened
uh and there's a lot of evidence to
digest this is that that mechanism we
learned to map
like a space is
was repackaged the same type of neurons
was repackaged into a more compact form
and that became the cortical column and
it was
it was in some sense genericized if
that's a word it was turned into a very
specific thing about learning
maps of environments to learning maps of
anything
learning a model of anything not just
your space but coffee cups and so on
and it got sort of repackaged
into a more compact version made a more
universal version
and then replicate it so the reason
we're so flexible is we have a very
generic
version of this mapping algorithm and we
have 150
000 copies of it sounds a lot like the
progress of deep learning
how so uh so take neural networks that
seem to work well for a specific task uh
compress them and uh multiply it
by a lot and then you just stack them on
top of it it's like the story of
transformers and uh yeah
but they've learned the networks they
end up
you're replicating an element but you
still need the entire network to do
anything
right here what's going on each
individual element is a complete
learning system this is why i can take a
human brain cut it in half and it still
works
it's pretty amazing it's fundamentally
distributed it's fundamentally
distributed complete modeling systems
so but that's that's our story we like
to tell
i i i would guess it's it's likely
largely right um but you know it's
there's a lot of evidence supporting
that story this evolutionary story
um the thing which brought me to this
idea is that the human brain
got big very quickly so that
that led to the proposal a long time ago
that well there's this common element
just instead of
creating new things it just replicated
something we also are extremely flexible
we can learn things that we had no
history about
right and so that tells it that the
learning algorithm is very
generic it's very kind of universal
because it's it doesn't assume any
prior knowledge about what it's learning
and
so you combine those things together and
you say okay well how did that come
about where did that universal algorithm
come from it had to come from something
that wasn't universal it came from
something that was more specific
and so anyway this led to our hypothesis
that you would find grid cells and place
cell equivalents in the neocortex
and when we first published our first
papers on this theory
we didn't know of evidence for that it
turns out there was some but we didn't
know about it
and since then so then we became aware
of evidence for grid cells in parts of
the neural cortex
and then now there's been new evidence
coming out there's some
interesting papers that came out just
january of this year so our one of our
predictions was
if this evolutionary hypothesis is
correct we would see grid cell place
cell equivalents cells that work like
them
through every column in the near cortex
and that's starting to be seen
what does it mean that uh why is it
important that they're present
because it tells us well we're asking
about the evolutionary origin of
intelligence right
so our theory is that these columns in
the cortex
are working on the same principles
they're modeling systems and it's hard
to imagine how neurons do this and so we
said
hey it's really hard to imagine how
neurons could learn
these models of things we can talk about
the details of that if you want
but let's um but there's this other part
of the brain
we know that learns models of
environments so could that
mechanism learn to model this room be
used to learn a model the water bottle
is it the same mechanism so we said it's
much more likely the brain is using the
same mechanism
which case it would have these
equivalent cell types
so it's basically the whole theory is
built on the idea that
these columns have reference frames and
they're learning these models and these
these grid cells create these reference
frames so it's it's basically um
the major in some sense the major
predictive uh part of this theory
is that we will find these equivalent
mechanisms in each column in the near
cortex which tells us that's
that that that's what they're doing
they're learning these sensory motor
models
of the world um so just to we're pretty
confident that would happen but now
we're seeing the evidence
so the evolutionary process nature does
a lot of copy and paste
and see what happens yeah yeah there's
no direction to it but
but um it just found out like hey if i
took this
these elements and and made more of them
what happens and let's hook them up to
the eyes and let's look up the ears and
and um and that seems to work pretty
well yeah like for us
again just to take a quick step back to
our
conversation of collective intelligence
do you sometimes
see that as just another copy and paste
aspect is uh copying pasting these uh
brains and
in humans and making a lot of them and
then creating uh
social structures that then almost
operates as a single brain
uh i wouldn't have said it but you said
it sounded pretty good
so to you the brain is fundamental is uh
is like a
is its own thing right i mean our goal
is to understand how the neurocortex
works
we can argue how essential that is to
understand the human
brain because it's not the entire human
brain you can argue how essential that
is to
understanding human intelligence you can
argue how essential it is to
um to uh you know sort of communal
intelligence
um i i'm not i didn't our goal was to
understand the near quarter yeah so what
is the neural cortex
and where does it fit in um the various
aspects of what the brain does
like how important is it to you well
obviously
again we i mentioned again in the
beginning it's it's it's
about 70 to 75 of the volume of a human
brain
so it's you know it dominates our brain
in terms of size not in terms of number
of neurons but
in terms of size size isn't everything
jeff
i know but it's it's something it's
nothing
it's not that we know that all
high-level vision
hearing and touch happens in the near
cortex we know that all language
occurs and is understood in the
neurocortex whether that's spoken
language written language sign language
with
language and mathematics language of
physics music
math you know we know that all
high-level planning and thinking occurs
in the neural cortex
if i were to say you know what part of
your brain designed a computer
and understands programming and and
creates music it's all the neurocortex
so then that's just kind of an
undeniable fact
uh if but then there's other parts of
our brain are important too
right our emotional states uh our body
regulating our body
um so the way i like to look at it is
you know could you can you understand
the neocortex about the rest of the
brain
and some people say you can't and i
think absolutely you can
um it's not that they're not interacting
but you can understand
can you understand the neural cortex
without understanding the emotions of
fear yes you can
you can understand how the system works
it's just a modeling system
i make the analogy in the book that it's
it's like a map of the world
and how that map is used depends on
who's using it
so how our map of our world in our you
know cortex
how we how we manifest as a human
depends on the rest of our brain what
are our motivations you know what are my
desires am i a nice guy or not a nice
guy am i a cheater or a
you know or not a cheater um uh you know
how important
different things are in my life so um
so but that the neoquatrex can be
understood on its own
um and and i say that as a
neuroscientist i know there's
all these interactions and i i want to
say i don't know them and we don't think
about it but
from a lay person's point of view you
can say it's a modeling system
i don't tend to think too much about the
communal aspect of intelligence which
you brought up a number of times already
so that's not really been my concern i
just wonder if there's a continuum
you